sometimes your very first party so are
we cool like are we in agreement
[Music]
abcdefg I have to know honestly I'm just
a Joanie who want to look at her after
the whole email situation I don't think
she wants to hurt your feelings I think
she just communicates differently I love
that the voice changes when you talk to
him oh my god do you want me to talk
super loud I don't want to waste my
summer at some camp I'm saying great for
crying out loud
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'm going to fit my
entire body in this box
[Music]
and we used to love this place three
years ago we were campers yeah man this
is where connect three connected I have
not gotten out of these sweatpants for
about five days and I have no plan on
doing it anytime soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so the three of us here are going to be
sneaking into some of the screenings of
our new movie 5 p.m. Park wearing the
city I was born and grew up
[Music]
[Applause]
there he look all right Lilly come on
[Music]
[Music]